today's question comes from jack in
pennsylvania says i'm struggling to
decide whether to leave my job i'm a 31
year old attorney making 154 000
a year i've been the in-house counsel
for family owned business for two years
a very profitable company but our boss
and founder has severe personal problems
he's engaged in illegal drug use for
decades
and suffers from severe mental illness
everyone in the company is afraid of him
and morale is low
we stay because our high salaries and
fear
that every boss is like this am i a
crybaby for wanting to quit
no you're not a crybaby wait a minute i
don't have any illegal drug users yeah i
do have severe mental illness well it
depends on what article you read
it has been reported that you do i will
tell you that
that is that is true uh but let me just
blow this myth up every boss is not like
this
you know i know dave that a lot of
people who are in toxic work situations
what happens is it becomes so toxic and
there's a fear of change
like domestic violence it is they'll put
up with it because i found that humans
are
are more willing to be miserable than
uncomfortable
and when he leaves this is a successful
lawyer 31 years of age making 154 a year
you can make that somewhere else i would
suggest to you there's several places
jack where you can make way more than
that as a lawyer so number one every
boss is not like this number two
you're not a crybaby you should quit but
i don't believe in jumping even at the
money you make so here's what i'd say
bite the stick start looking find
something else
sign a deal and walk in there and say
it's been great i'm out
yep yep and don't try to uh rebuke
no i'm mentally ill no toxic no sense in
blowing up a bridge no
just go uh it was good thanks yeah i got
moving on
bigger and better things next appreciate
the opportunity next year
yeah my goodness drug use for decades
and you're an attorney
yeah yeah and you're in you're you're an
accessory what
yeah dave i just want to say something
really quick on this i just because i
hear this every day on the ken coleman
show i'm trying to help people
pursue meaningful work so if you're if
you're new to me here on the ramsay show
that's what we're doing because we
believe that
that that everybody longs to make a
difference in the world and through your
work
and your relationships is how you do it
we focus on the work side
but i see this every day and here's
another case jack represents all of us
there's so many of you out there that
are watching listening today you know
you're supposed to leave for a myriad of
reasons it's not where you're supposed
to be
and and one of the big reasons that
people don't leave dave is because
they're so scared of the unknown and so
they're like i'm miserable but i
know what misery looks like i don't know
what change
looks like and so here's how you step
into that
when you the fear is of the unknown so
what's the antithesis to that the known
go get some answers go dig go do some
research
is a require resignation letter go look
go look and begin to see what's out
there when you begin to see the answers
and then you see oh there's a path and
there's another stone and another stone
another
and then all of a sudden it's not so
scary but i'm telling you
uh fear of the unknown is keeping people
from from leaving miserable situations
number one
and finding meaning in their work to
show up every day
like i do here and get to do something i
love that produces results that
we were out feed my soul yeah we were on
the farm the other day and um
doing some shooting a bunch of us and um
doing some
tactical pistol stuff anyway one of the
cars got his truck stuck in the mud
and you know there's two or three number
one somebody else can pull you out yes
that's what ended up happening here
actually but um but i've got my truck
stuck
in the mud many times and you know one
thing you have to do is you have to
kind of get you gun it and get it moving
and kind of get it rocking back and
forth
and and then you gun it and you jump out
of it you don't
you don't kind of like crawl slowly out
you got to get a little rock going then
you got to punch it so jack what i'm
going to tell you is you need to get a
little rock going and you need to punch
it
meaning that your hesitation in this
highly toxic situation
is going to lead you to want to stick
your toe in the water i don't want you
stick your toe in the water i want you
to go
on 10 interviews in the next 30 days
that's exactly i want you to do this get
it i'm out
go yes you got to get out of there
now yes and you need to go look for lots
of jobs and interviews and all of a
sudden you're going to get confidence
that
it's okay yes and but you can't go on
one no
no and here's the other thing once you
do this jack you're gonna find
that this is the nudge you've been
needing you finally got to your breaking
point please don't be like jack jack's a
good guy but don't wait until you're
miserable
you know you don't even have to work for
a bad company you just got to not like
that company
that's all it is like we've got one of
our senior developers here the
top top web guy or
coding yeah you know what uh techno
technology guys senior developer i mean
this is big time oh yeah
and he worked at microsoft for a while
and matter of fact before he came to us
he left seattle and came here
came to work for us and he was one of
the top guys i mean some of the stuff he
wrote inside microsoft
was absolutely amazing and so why did he
come to work for ramsey well number one
we won bless best place to work last
year in the nation
okay and microsoft didn't okay they're
not a bad they're not bad people i'm not
running them down
but he looked up and said i want to
write code for
and i want to train young coders how to
write code for
something that matters yes i don't want
to just write it
just out into oblivion yes just ones and
zeroes out into the universe
you know and not have any idea that it
changed someone's life but when you're
writing code
you know here it's life-changing you're
setting king coleman up
to completely change the entire culture
in america
away from toxic work and you're setting
rachel cruz and ken and chris hogan and
dave ramsey up
to get to change the entire culture
inside of america when you're writing
code
to create a situation where the credit
card becomes the cigarette of the
financial world
where peop where so many people have
paid off their student loans
and gotten free that their life was
transformed
because people like you were writing
that code he wanted to be involved in
something like that
and by the way we're hiring more yes
right now yeah we need them we got lots
of technology needs right now lots of
senior coder you're out there listening
man i need you you know product
designers we need you
you know front-end back-end platform we
need you
i mean we need you you go to
daveramsey.com and click on the we're
hiring thing i mean i'll just turn this
into an employment ad yeah by the way
tell them that ken recommended you and i
might get a little bit of a bonus on
that does that work that way dave
no it doesn't they actually had for them
to actually have to know me no no you
don't get anything
i thought i was going to get that
you're not you're not that you're not in
that you're not that's not part of your
comp plan
i folks we are looking for this it's a
toxic work environment ken you're not
getting money with that
[Laughter]
but you were saying i'm sorry i just
have committees we recommend people now
i mean but the point is
yeah that we've got we've got we have we
have a
we have a legal team here we've got a
you know chief counsel
several attorneys on our sharp lawyers
because we've got all these uh
governance and all these contracts and
all these other things that we get into
hardly ever get into litigation but
occasionally we have to deal with that
too
but uh most i mean it's trademarking and
all these other stuff
and so you know that the guy that's our
senior legal counsel same situation he
came out of
uh you know a situation that wasn't
toxic
it wasn't that bad but it was just
didn't matter
what he was doing wasn't making a dent
in the universe
you know apple i love that was one of
their vision things i want to make a
dent in the universe
we want to make a dent in the
transformation of people's lives in
ramsey and we are doing that absolutely
we're in the process of doing that i
mean we're
we're changing massive numbers of
people's lives here
absolutely and so when you're our legal
counsel you know you're not having to
work for a guy like this guy
and no you're not a crybaby for wanting
to have meaning to your work
that's just called being wise by the way
that's written on your heart
i'm just going to tell you your creator
writes it on your heart nobody has to
teach a person
to want to make a difference you know
just like you don't have to teach a
toddler to take a toy from another
toddler or a lie
or to say no that's it's all on it we
all want to
matter we want to make a difference and
some of you listening right now are
doing the right thing in the wrong place
some of you don't know what the right
thing is some of you know what it is
but you know how to get there some of
you know what it is know how to get
there and you're scared to take the leap
uh we'll take those calls dave and i
would love to help you on that
we believe in you because we believe
that you were created philly unique role
that you were needed and you must do it
yep kencoleman.com to get information on
what ken's talking about daveramsey.com
if one of those
positions sounds like something you need